move the orange dot to 9/4 on the number
lines let's think about this number line
right here this is 0 this is 3 so this
must be 1 & 2 we need to go to 9 forts
so there's two ways of thinking about 9
4 it's one way is to try to convert it
to a mixed number 4 goes into 9 2 times
and you'll have 1 left over so this you
could use 2 and 1/4 so you could say
this is 2 or this is 1 2 and then we
have to go 1/4 of the way between 2 & 3
so that looks like about 2 and 1/4 so
you could think about it that way or you
could even view it as an improper
fraction so let's go by fourths so
that's 1/4 2/4 3/4 4/4 which is a whole
5/4 6/4 7/4 8/4 which is equal to 2
wholes 8 divided by 4 is 2 and then we
go from 8 forts to 9 4 it's either way
we get to the exact same point on the
number line let's do a few more of these
move the orange dot to eleven fifths on
the number line so we can do it both
ways again 5 goes into 11 two times and
then you have 1 left over so you could
call this 2 and 1/5 so you could go one
two and then 1/5 or we could just think
of it in terms of fifths as an improper
fraction 1/5 2/5 3/5 4/5 5/5 as a whole
6/5 7/5 8/5 9 fifths 10 fifths 10
divided by 5 is 2 10 fifths is 2 wholes
10 fifths and eleven fifths I'm having
more fun than I expected too with this
exercise let's do one more orange dot 2
5 halves on the number line
so this is one half this is two halves
which is the whole this is three halves
this is four halves which is two wholes
this is 5 halves another way you could
have thought about it 2 goes into 5 2
times with a remainder 1 so this is 2
and 1/2 as a mixed number
1 2 and 1/2 as
next number